good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday don't let
the mondays get you down you guys rise
and grind rise and grind
it's a very monday monday monday ugh
but i have rose i have groaned
and that's truly all that matters yeah
it's really the first step towards
getting through the day yeah but you
know we actually have a lot to cover
today
and so for that i'm excited to get so
much off my chest
do you ever like have trouble sleeping
because you have so much to say the next
morning and like
you're not gonna be able to be at peace
until you get things off your chest
only when what i have to say is either
like addressing something
controversial or like i need where i'm
about to like have such a hot take that
i need to get all my words in order
do you have a hot take today no no no
i'm just like we i watched so much
content this weekend i literally did not
leave my bed
um so i just have so many many thoughts
to share yeah jackie and i
both watched the first episode of the
gossip girl reboot we both
watched the real housewives of potomac
season premiere
last night and we're gonna be talking
about it in the tv recap because we
caught up on long island so yes we did
you're gonna be you're more caught up
than i am so we're just gonna like talk
about our initial thoughts
and i read it ends with us oh my god you
did
i did okay segment what are what were
your thoughts you know what i really
really liked it like i was ready to be
like colleen hoover like you know
they're losing their virginities they're
15 but like well that book
that we both read that margaret
recommended about like the teenagers
losing their virginity finding carter
it's the worst book it's and it's crazy
because i would say
maybe i don't know how many five star
books i have that aren't like celebrity
memoirs
most of them are by colleen hoover ugly
love by colleen hoover's also a great
one that you might like
it ends with us is premium and margot
recommended my first colleen hoover book
what was that one called
hopeless hopeless atrocious yeah
atrocious there was like a nice little
twist at the end but it didn't matter
because like what got us there was just
so
unsettling yeah i totally agree but this
was not that
this was very good i read it in you know
less than 24 hours and i really enjoyed
it i was like look
when i woke up on saturday morning i was
like excited to finish it yeah so
i really appreciated your recommendation
that's my first book i've ever
recommended
it was nice to just breeze through
something but it had a lot of heart
yes and so i really enjoyed it and then
i went to watching tv like just the rest
of the weekend my weekend was really
sort of
i mean can we talk about the book oh i
mean what else is there to say okay so
like there's a few things to say one
like when she actually in the book
said it ends with us like did you get
chills because i did yes but i had
realized previously
what she was referring to then like i
when i first picked up the book i
thought it ends with us means like oh
we're end game like yes we
it ends with us and then once i realized
she was breaking the cycle of abuse
i was like uh spoiler alert
i was like it ends with them i didn't
get it until
she said it in the book it was stunning
once i realized that that's what it was
i was like i wonder if she's gonna say
the title in the book so when it came i
was like perfect
okay and also i really felt like the
book was
really well done maybe i'm like looking
too much into it but like
it was a journey like for me because
like you're so shipping her in this
first guy
and then this like first night happens
you're like well was it an accident you
feel like you're actually going through
the cycle of emotions
like what it's like to be in that
situation because i'm like there's no
way like it was definitely an accident
like
everything's their life is perfect yeah
so i just i
loved it like everybody really did a
good job and i was reading her like
authors notes at the end of like what
she was like did you read the
no but jillian was telling me it's
inspired by her mom yeah so
um she really did a good job of like
trying to get you into that perspective
and like have the same
thoughts that lily might have had and
i'm sure that was like hard to achieve
um but it was really really well done i
agree that first night i was like
no way no yeah also um it
has been purchased by hollywood justin
baldoni
is involved in the project in some way i
don't know like if that means it's
actually coming but
i have heard and read articles that it
is is theo eating something he's eating
a bone like a
perfect boy that he is a perfect man so
perfect so wonderful
i'm so glad you like the book like that
makes me so happy yeah and so for my
next book
choice for my next trick i don't know
what path i'm gonna go down you know i
feel like i'm at a crossroads
i've kind of tied up all these tunnels
and now i'm ready for
for a new tunnel so i don't know where
i'm gonna go from here it'll be
interesting i heard girls no job the
crazy beautiful life of an instagram
there's monster available on amazon and
all platforms where you can get audio
print or digital books
i heard that was a great one yeah it has
like like a lot of reviews on amazon and
a lot of them are nice
it does i was actually looking at that
recently the thing is i've read it three
times
so um i don't think i'm going to read it
again no but i've heard
i have heard that the fourth time is
like really kind of this transformative
experience that is what i've heard
okay that's good to know i'm glad you've
read it as many times as i have
yeah it's so good like on my goodreads
it says read three times yes
um okay well i'm so glad you liked my
recommendation
yes thank you so much and then i spent
the rest of my weekend watching the show
medici on netflix it's a historical show
based in truth but you know they have to
put their lies in there too like
to make drama even though it's like such
a dramatic period of time and like
they're still making
sully like sully and they're still
making [ __ ] up but even though like
steli
at the end of the day like wasn't really
a story that required a movie but
yeah because there was no like adversity
or no plot like it was just a true
heroic moment
yeah but then they threw in this whole
like proper diavra about this
like committee i don't know yeah but all
the committee stuff if you guys um are
curious the stuff
about insulin about the committee like
nobody was pressing sully about whether
he should or shouldn't have landed in
the
hudson and also like the way they
fetishize the hudson was like really
[ __ ] weird do you think that there is
a single soul on this earth who knows
more about the sully movie and the sully
story than you
it might be brian kelly but i'm just
gonna say i think there has to be
because i'm not even like an
aviation person um but i don't know if
there's anyone on this earth who like
stands sully no who like sully the movie
the man
and the story live rent-free in your
mind you know
as they should as they should it's
really a beautiful story except for
those pesky birds
those were the villains totally yeah
they should have had like an animated
an animated like prequel about the birds
and they're playing and they like woke
up on the wrong side of the bed
and like what led them to that decision
yeah i think that would have been great
that would be crazy um so anyways medici
is
really good i've just finished season
two it's like honestly really stressful
and like the medicis were like so
powerful but of course the show only
like focuses on like their
trials and tribulations and never the
success which is just bothersome about
shows in general like can't we like
enjoy the good times too it was i was
just like
stressed out but then season two ended
in a really crazy way
so i'm gonna watch season three um it
has so many actors from game of thrones
in it it was really crazy like richard
madden is the star in the first season
so handsome and crazily enough he
is like in a scene with walder frey and
he winds up marrying
her daughter his daughter his daughter
right so it's like
that's crazy it's really crazy because
you know that's why he died
um spoiler alert and then also ned stark
is in it
and he is spoiler alert the villain
in a big major way and it's really
it's interesting so i started manifest
i saw your story but i didn't watch it
because i was tapping through to see
ben's reaction about gossip girl are you
trying to hurt my feelings
i'm trying to be honest i'm trying to
keep it real with you okay well
i start everyone's talking about the
show right so i'm like me and ben were
looking for something you know to start
together we liked lost
kind of so we were just looking for to
go on a journey together
and i swear i thought i thought i
started watching the wrong show because
this thing that i was watching was
actual
community theater it was an insult to
hallmark like the acting i was shook i'm
like
i was sure sure that i put on the wrong
show
so then there was the plane well yeah so
then i looked up it's like the plane the
five years like that's not a spoiler
it's the
like i've never watched and i know that
so i'm like
what this cannot be it so i'm like you
know let me give it pilots are always
weird let me give it like three episodes
and it's just getting like worse and
worse and what's troublesome is that
it's actually like a decent premise for
a show
right adjusting to life when you've been
missing for five years but for you it
only feels like you've been missing for
a day
and i'm just like frustrated that they
did what they did because it's so bad
when it's like a decent premise even
though
a lot of it is definitely lifted from
lost so there's like this number the
number of the plane is following them
around and like that's literally what
loss was like
whatever it's atrocious i did stop
watching it and
went on to other things that we're going
to talk about in the tv recap we are
going to talk about in the tv recap
really excited to talk about gossip girl
talk about community theater
some of the worst acting i've ever seen
i can't i let's just i cannot wait to
talk about it okay so do you think that
without further ado
to do are you all caught up how was your
birthday
yeah thanks for remembering um it was
great you know i really was not like
other girls on my birthday like i feel
like i was so chill
you know i just woke up and like me and
ben i went to return you know a couple
of the gifts that i had gotten which
were
so thoughtful but just not for me so
excited to announce that she did not
return my gift i actually wore it
on saturday i'm obsessed i made it i'm
safe yes i did good
but some of the other gifts mostly from
ben um one for margo sorry margo
um she returned your gift yeah so it's
just at this point it's just an exchange
of credits you know yes
um so then we did that we had like a
lovely lunch i went over to michaela's
house
and then we went to a baseball game
which like i said i'm
not like other girls spending my day at
a baseball game but it was like
so fun first of all like
gorgeous night you know like not too hot
not too cold even though it did start to
rain like a little bit at the end but
then we left
um and it was just fabulous like
i don't know there was just something
about the energy the mexican you know
so much alcohol so much food it was just
really fun like i highly recommend going
to a baseball game on your birthday it's
just like hours of sitting
drinking fun which is really my personal
aesthetic plus if you like baseball
there's that too
oh yeah which i do like baseball ben's
friend plays on the mets he hit a home
run and it was just like
a homer it was such a thrill you know
like
mets fans are nuts though like truly
nuts
it was just thrilling you know like i've
never been so excited to see a home run
before
and it was fun and then we watched the
fight i know you didn't watch i didn't
watch but we're gonna talk about the
fight okay so i got some thoughts
yeah we have one story about the fight
and then you can share all your fight
thoughts
but those are my birthday thoughts it
was just like really chill you know like
not like other girls like i don't like
to make a big deal on my birthday
after having two parties yes so so chill
i really don't like to make it a big
deal
um well we're so glad that you turned 27
in an extremely chill way
claude getting older is only sad if you
are living in a state of denial
therefore i am sad i'm in denial about a
lot of things
claude calling you i don't know
it's just upsetting like like
i'm so far away from high school does
that does that make sense don't be like
that like
who wants to be in high school look at
gossip girl no i know but like i
actually had a good time in high school
and like i'm just getting like further
and further away and i'm like
oh my god i'm like so old but you're
getting closer like you should look for
you have to have things to look forward
to you can't only just like look at the
past like
aren't you excited to like you know be a
lady who lunches one day and like
yeah i am i am but also like
i think what lies ahead for the future
like also gives me anxiety because some
people like run into the future like
ready to have kids like i'm not
yeah so now i just feel like that was
each year that i get closer it's like
less acceptable for me to say that
okay that's fair but you know what
normalize doing what feels right for you
yeah no i'm working on it i really am
i'm working on the normalization but
it's not easy
no no it's not it ain't okay well thank
you for opening up to us
sure it's my pleasure and now i think
without further
ado do where are you being here right
perfect
eating a bone it is time for the past
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
no oh no
she's back the power of christ compels
me to tell you that today's episode
is brought to you by away away is the
modern lifestyle brand that creates
thoughtful products for every traveler
and every kind of trip
they started with the perfect suitcase
crafted with features that make travel
more seamless and now when travel looks
more different than ever before
you can count on a ways range of
suitcases bags and accessories whenever
you take your next trip
i just have to say i have had the same
one away suitcase for years and i took
that thing on me on with me
i took that thing with me on tour to 60
cities
doesn't even have a scratch it's
literally the best suitcase and it's
true i don't
they say like it is the perfect suitcase
and it just is like the compartments
that thing in the middle the zippers
the laundry bag like the hard shell soft
interior
it is really just the best suitcase and
it's so worth just investing in one good
suitcase because it'll last you so long
and they're also really cute which also
doesn't they're cute and the sizes are
perfect because you can have the
carry-on one you can have a super big
one for when you want to check luggage
but they also the in-betweener the
in-between don't sleep on the medium
size because sometimes you don't need
the biggest bag available but you do
want to check luggage
all of their suitcases are designed to
last a lifetime with durable exteriors
that can withstand even the roughest of
bag handlers
very true also it comes with a little
sponge
which is great for getting out scuffs i
didn't know that and it was it's in this
like shiny little
tinfoil thing and it's it comes out
immediately
um all this all the suitcases come with
an interior organization
system it includes a built-in
compression pad to help you pack more
a hidden and removable laundry bag that
separates your dirty clothes because you
guys know like there's nothing more
embarrassing than having a compartment
of dirty underwear that like tsa looks
through so
away has really thought of everything um
they have a tsa approved combination
lock that keeps all your belongings safe
and it's
available in different materials like
polycarbonate aluminum and durable nylon
and a variety of colors and styles
they're all designed to last a lifetime
they have 100 day trial on everything
that they make
so you can take the product on the road
live with it travel with it get lost
with it for 100 days
if you decide it's not for you you can
return any non-personalized items for a
full refund during that period
and they offer free shipping and returns
so start your 100 day trial and shop the
entire away lineup of travel essentials
including their best-selling suitcases
at away travel dot com slash toast
that's away travel dot com slash toast
sign on travel easily truly
okay first story a little ufc fight news
and then we'll talk about the rest of
the fight but addison rey's responding
to backlash over her ufc
gig saying y'all got me fired the
influencer said she got fired after
sports fans took issue with her recent
gig conducting a red carpet interview
for ufc and her quip
that she quotes studied broadcast
journalism in college for three whole
months to prepare for this moment
then she tweeted a few hours later never
mind y'all got me fired
she covered a preliminary event for
saturday's big ufc 264 where dustin
poirier
spoiler alert beat connor mcgregor um
she was conducting the interview with
him because they are apparently from the
same hometown yes he's from louisiana
but people took issue
with her tweet that said an instagram
post i studied broadcast journalism in
college for three whole months to
prepare for this moment
which was obviously a joke um i don't
think she got fired i think like it was
it was a one-off
it was a joke it was a one-off gig yeah
um but i don't think she was like the
next joe rogan
no i have a lot of thoughts on this
because i feel like we were just talking
about this when laverne cox
got the job at juliana rancic's job yeah
because it really is like this new world
we're living in where people with
platforms are becoming eligible for jobs
that you once had to
study for it's like this new world we're
living in and of course like it it's
great in some ways but it's difficult
for other people trying to break into
the business and i really do totally get
that
um at some point it's just like i don't
think this is like a real
interviewee type of job it's just like a
press thing
i do think them choosing addison ray it
was an interesting choice like for
sports fans anyways
but like look it it's making news people
are talking about the fight that
probably weren't even talking about it
so
i don't know i think it's fine like the
joke was funny it's not the joke was
funny and i think what she was trying to
say is actually most people most
celebrities who go on to
do like talking head stuff which there
are so many have no experience in
journalism they probably
didn't study it right but like she
studied journalism for three months it
was a
joke ha ha lol like really not that
serious ha ha
laugh funny
laughs funny people just will be upset
about anything depending on the person
like some people can get away with
everything but addison's one of those
people where people like
really no talent i'm sorry like
homegirl say what you want there's some
talent there you have to have some ounce
of talent to get from where she was to
where she is
like in so many different ways not only
to just be like a successful influencer
but to be addison ray who's actually the
creme de la creme
of influence influencing and finding a
mainstream career
yeah 100 so i don't know i just like
hate these pylons and i think that
again i always just come on here um
always trying to advocate
on behalf of the influencer because
we're just like constantly getting [ __ ]
on as like
illegitimate business people and it's
just like annoying you know
yeah no i agree you're bothered by
addison ray's success you are
and it's time you look in the mirror and
accept that because she's literally 11
years old
and has multi-million dollars so i'm
upset too it's fine
but like that is what it is life isn't
fair you guys
you know what it is yes
yes life isn't fair and it's not addison
ray's job to not take a job so it
doesn't upset you
life isn't fair right and just because
you go to school for how many years for
something like
still doesn't mean that you necessarily
are going to get that job especially
when there's only a handful of jobs and
it's based on like talent
knowledge and a millionaire and a
million other things yeah no but like
life is just not fair
it's so true and i think we need to
remember that more people have forgotten
no because i think
like our generation life to be fair our
generation like expects the world to
like cater to
them when so so much of the human
experience
is getting out and getting upset and
getting rejection
yeah and it's like we have forgotten
that yeah
and addison ray is here to remind us
yes it's an important lesson yeah it is
it really is but the fight by the way i
watched like the last three fights
oh right on the card so like the third
to last one like the guy got knocked out
in
a minute and 30 seconds like it was
actually sad and i was like damn i
wanted to see like more fight
then the second to last one they went
all five rounds and holy [ __ ] i've never
been to warner my whole life so i'm like
which one do i like better
then the conor mcgregor so i was like
rooting for conor mcgregor because he's
like funny and like
he kind of like is like an instagrammer
i don't know like what he does even
though the other guy was from america
and like i should have been supporting
america
and the guy from america are they
billing it as like
yes ufc everyone like holds their flag
and their pictures have their flags and
it's like an international competition
international affair yeah it's an
international lifestyle and i can't
believe sonia morgan wasn't in
attendance
yeah okay i didn't even know that i wish
i had watched honestly i had no clue it
was on
like because zach was busy and so
usually he's like oh you got to come
here
like because he'll be like travis and
courtney just like stuck each other's
tongues at each other right so i really
watched because
it's like a it's a huge stadium but the
seats around the ring are so close to
the ring so you can see every celebrity
i saw
miles and kelly teller i saw machine gun
megan
kelly i saw travis and courtney
um jonathan chabon like it was really a
star-studded event
um and that's why itunes did it but then
that last fight i have to say like
i actually have chills coming down my
spine so here's what happened
conor mcgregor is just like a [ __ ]
talker like he talks [ __ ] about everyone
and he's lost like three fights in a row
now so it's like you gotta stop talking
[ __ ]
so he's losing like really bad this
guy's just and ufc is different than
like floyd mayweather boxing like
there's it's no holds barred you could
technically die in the ring like
it's blood i just learned that recently
that if you were to
kill someone in the ring it's legal
manslaughter
legal killing no it's crazy and so like
they get bloody there's blood all over
the ring
it's nuts and so conor mcgregor is
getting his ass
beat his ear is like falling off he's so
bloody
he gets back up there's not a lot of
time left in this particular round
and the other guy portier punches him
connor dodges it but loses his footing
at the same time
and literally snaps his ankle
in half they kept replaying it in slow
motion i wanted to vomit
oh he couldn't get up you know how at
the end sometimes they call it like if
you
not going to finish the whole round like
it's clear that there's a winner and
like
ethically the doctors don't want you
know that person competing anymore they
stand up and
you know you do the hand thing yeah
connor couldn't even get up for the hand
thing he literally sat in the corner
like
getting his ankle wrapped like screaming
like your wife is in my dms like he's
insane
but the ankle stepping was so chilling
bone chilling
and honestly shame on you espn plus
played it a thousand times i was gonna
puke it was putrid he like slipped and
it cracked and it was just so disgusting
um but it was a wild ride he literally
left the arena
in a stretcher and was like oh [ __ ] you
like he was being crazy
that sounds really entertaining it was
that's really sad that he snapped his
ankle i hope no one stole his comp
hurry on top of it oh i really hope so
for him
jackie you're a conspiracy theorist
because
you have claimed for years that when we
were on olivia's bachelorette party
literally in the middle of the night
you're right was in the middle of it was
hurting we hadn't gone to bed yet
you said somebody snapped my wrist and
then you can find your chapstick and you
said they also stole your kopari
and i just want to let you know you did
not sit next to stanley tucci on the
plane ride home from la
and nobody snapped your wrist or stole
your crepari wow
see the memory of you
you know where the kopari was found in
margaret's makeup case
in your makeup case oh please you know i
don't even like the kopari chapstick
yes you do oh i was like oh it's too
tinted like i if you don't know like you
end up looking like director
and here's the thing like i can give you
the benefit of the down and say like it
was probably an
accident or you probably dropped it in
like why would it be on me i did not
steal your
help i'm trying to say like i have no i
need help i didn't steal your i
want to forgive you i didn't steal your
co-party and
margot snapped your wrist so i'm not
crazy my kopari was missing and my wrist
was snapped
so you want to take back what you said i
don't know why don't you just go over to
floyd mayweather's house i know
conor mcgregor's house you guys can
describe we can talk about it together
yeah yeah he can write
two irish redheads anyways thank you for
proving my point though
no i didn't know such things no you
literally nothing of the sort you
you did so thank you it was a great
fight it was exciting thrilling celebs
were out
everyone was in vegas dave chappelle was
there um now
and joe rogan is like
he literally was like he always does
like you know he wears the headsets and
like i mean he came up
from ufc yeah but i don't know if he
always did this after each fight he got
in the ring with the winner
he saw the pictures and he had to get
down on the floor to sit next to conor
mcgregor and give him an interview it
was
hilarious i saw him really funny you
just love to see like a small indie
podcaster you're getting out there and
getting opportunities we're so happy for
him
so happy for him no that makes sense
yeah um
i bet he didn't go to journalism school
so that's so true
if you want to take that up with him um
i'm sure he'll
i'm sure he'll put you in your pocket
and you know what now that i think about
it in
sports a lot it's like a thing once you
graduate from being sports
doing sports you become a broadcaster
right like ben's favorite show
nba and tnt is like half like i guess a
traditional journalist and half former
basketball players yeah that's just like
the cycle of life in sports and addison
ray has
literally won the championship of
tick-tock dances
and now she's retiring in doing sports
broadcasting but also
in defense of influencers a lot of being
an influencer
is showcasing your personality not for
everyone but for a lot of people and
addison ray i think
has gotten to where she is because she's
a really good dancer and like all of
these things and she's so cute
not but because her like people like her
personality and that's what interviewing
people is about
yeah and it's like i just can't explain
it's not you know a diane sawyer sit
down interview it's like a red carpet
like instagram live like
it's really not that deep it's not
that's making a joke like
i i just can't understand everyone who's
really so
so upset yeah and i just like i i hate
this world that we're living in we're
like someone just can't make a joke
someone just can't make a joke like
don't it's not a big deal
yeah joke okay well are you ready for
our next story it's a little happy
couple news i like em but i'm really
distracted by there's appears to be
something in theo's
coat will you just oh i saw it this
morning it looks like
not something i want to touch like it
it's like grease and
what is it do you know what happened
i don't know but it appears to be like
tacky like tar
yeah or grease or gum i'll get it out
after i just thought maybe it was like
something i could pull out i
when he walked and i thought it was a
twig and then yeah i quickly realized it
wasn't
poor angel i'm sorry so much maybe some
happy couple news to cheer you up oh
definitely adele shops at outlet mall
with rumored boyfriend
skepta okay i'm more interested in the
outlet mall okay yes i know that you are
page six is told that shoppers at the
cabazone outlets a discount mall just
outside san bernardino california
we're stunned to see the rolling in the
deep singer in the discount prada store
there
oh and by the way she seems to be dating
that rapper she said she wasn't dating
what's his name skepta i don't think
i've ever heard of him and i didn't know
that there were any rumors
there were i feel like i remember seeing
rumors but then she also like said she
was single on snl so people were like
okay maybe not but
um she's living her best friend so they
were spotted together at the prada
outlet i just want to say like
couldn't be me you know most profound
singer of a generation shopping at a
discount store like
that would just not be me like if i was
like a true celebrity with access to
true celebrity wealth like
you could not pull me off of like the
true rodeo drive like
i don't know if they're like driving
through san bernardino maybe like this
is a renowned
outlet store you can find things that
you wouldn't ordinarily be able to find
there are renowned outlet stores i
actually have been to one
in florence and it was heaven and i was
like
having the time of my life but i just
like i guess that's just me
you know like being greedy but to me the
real story here is
adele discount shopping yeah no i agree
it's like two big stories put together
yeah yeah and if she made investments
wonder if she got anything anything good
yeah i'm happy for her
in this new relationship i'm not gonna
put all my eggs in a basket
i know nothing about it's early um again
just looking hopefully he makes her feel
a wide range of emotions that inspire
ballads you know
um of course we wish for her happiness
but we also wish for a journey to get
there so that we can go on that journey
with her
yes i agree and i think that's important
just for like
the world yeah i also think it's worth
mentioning like some of the greatest
songwriters of our generation have
written their best music like while also
in a happy place like i think that
it's possible casey musgraves like has
written some of her best work like in
good times and in bad times happy and
sad
at the same time literally so i'm not
worried about adele's ability to produce
i just you know
a little heartbreak never hurt the heart
songwriting process
i agree just emotions period yeah i want
all the emotions i want like excessive
happiness
profound sadness like not that i'm
wishing sadness on a tail because she's
my girl but like you know
girls gotta eat we need a new album yeah
it's been quite a long time
it has been but it will be worth the
wait it always is it always is i
actually remember
um when that second album came out 25.
it's crazy she's only had two right
21 and 25. she's just ready
yeah well she wasn't really famous when
she had 19. but yeah sure that was like
the chasing payments sure
um when 25 came out it was like now like
a really long time ago
um i got it illegally downloaded
somebody sent it around
yeah yeah i think you got it too but i
don't to listen to it in my internet
crime i don't think i listen to it
because even sometimes
i get you know um album samplers from
the industry and i don't like to listen
to them before they're out because like
i feel like i can't enjoy it i can't
expect i definitely downloaded the
illegal version and listened to it like
on repeat
yeah i know that's not for me but it's
just one of the fun facts about myself
is that i had 25 before anyone else did
because like someone at work
when we were interns yeah shared it with
you yeah that's pretty cool
it was exciting excitement excites you
it does excite me do you want some more
happy couple news that is just so cute
and sweet
sure eddie murphy's son eric is dating
martin lawrence's
daughter jasmine daughter
that is lauren sorry that's really cute
lauren's daughter
okay that's so cute because you know
like the kids will be behaving they will
be treating each other right because
their parents are involved
yeah and they're like they'll always
make each other laugh says paige six
eddie murphy's son eric murphy
is dating martin lawrence's daughter
jasmine lawrence you know it's funny she
revealed their relationship in a sweet
instagram post celebrating his 32nd
birthday on saturday
eric murphy is the name of e from
entourage
so i just thought that was funny oh
that's hysterical no it's i'm dying
laughing it's the funniest thing i've
ever heard in my
life i'm going to write that into my
next show i know it's a joke people
yeah um this is so cute this is so cute
and so
sweet like you love to see it i love
just like celebrity kid news we should
have like a weekly segment the ckn
because
uh there's nothing i love more than
celebrity offspring oh i
i completely disagree there's actually
like i can't it depends what the news is
but when it's like
two people whose parents are friends and
funny
and they get together and it's like such
a cute relationship i'm so here for that
but like generally speaking i'm not here
for celebrity kids news
because you're a celebrity kid well you
know what i think that actually is a
really interesting conversation speaking
about addison ray like
okay so everyone's all upset
opportunities are going to addison ray
even though like she works
you know hard to create a platform and
she
is not undeserving of the role are there
other people who are deserving yes
i think an interesting conversation that
we like almost never have is like the
celebrity nepotism in the offspring like
i'm she's very talented kaya gerber like
overnight becoming the biggest model in
the world because her mom is cindy
crawford yeah there's so many examples i
can think of of like people
directing tv shows or just like acting
because they wanted to one day you know
right but also like
what i see more of just because like
this is what we do every day is just
like the headlines about like these
kids as if they're like celebrities
themselves and like we should care that
they took a [ __ ]
i don't care like if your parent took a
[ __ ] call me yeah
of course like we want the scoop but
like i really don't just because you're
someone's kid like i really don't care
what you're up to no of course not but i
do think that like
see maybe it's just because i'm an
influencer and i'm always like really
feeling on the defense about being an
influencer like i really don't
understand the backlash like an addison
ray would get for something like that
and again maybe that's just because i'm
biased but i feel like i actually could
understand like maybe reserve some of
that
some of that upsetness for like
celebrity offsprings getting
things literally out of nowhere just
because like they decided to one day
right i agree
that i can understand right i could
understand that too i don't think
there's you know
there's no not a lot of noise about that
no i'm saying like there's no outrage on
the celebrity nepotism
when actually that seems like a very
reasonable thing to be outraged about
yeah
i agree yeah here we are completely
agree even though
see i feel two ways because sometimes
i'm like with the celebrity offspring
like they just like decide to become
successful and they just get it it's
like kind of not fair
but also i do live for it like some of
my favorite people to follow
on tick tock are celebrity offsprings
not enough people
know that sandy cohen from
the oc's daughter has a tick tock and
it's pretty much just like her and sandy
they're swifties like
well his name is peter but it's premium
content courtney cox's daughter has a
tick tock laura dern's daughter has a
tick tock
so many famous people's kids have tick
tocks and the parents like slide in and
out and it's some of the best contests
iris iris apatow amazing tick tock just
something worth mentioning so
i yeah when i was on tick-tock
and oh you're like an old person now
back when i was on
dictionary i would see like um you know
the celebrity kids and then their
parents would come in and it's like oh
my god
yeah no i but i was not here for it oh i
love it no i was in love okay so you
know we just have different interests
because we are not like other girls and
we're so different from one another no
we couldn't have had more different life
experiences up until this point that led
us to have different opinions we
actually are
really different from each other we know
we actually are considering like we're
so similar no considering we've lived
like the same lives we couldn't be more
different like i feel like to the
outside eye like we're
the same person so similar we talk the
same do the same blah blah but like once
you know us you really see how different
we are
no no we're so different so different
are you ready for our next story i know
you're not ready because you're never
gonna be ready
no cause i'm a little hungry and i think
i'm just gonna go nibble on some
fabulous snacks from nuts.com
the best kept secret of savvy snackers
across the country
they have the best snacks i just feel
like it's time to elevate your pantry
what you're munching on
you gotta get into some chocolate toffee
cashews
bourbon pecans or pecans some
crystallized ginger they have honey
honey sesame sticks so they have a
variety of snacks and pantry items
including candies dried fruits and
pantry items like baking mixes
pasta and more they sell everything at
nuts.com obviously lots of really good
delicious nuts
but tons of other things and it's just
about time we stop like snacking on the
same chips from the grocery store like
we need to be elevated we're all getting
older like we're more mature and it's
just time to have organic
roasted salted nuts candy nuts any nuts
you can imagine nuts.com is here for you
and honestly
it's nuts it's nuts they have over 4000
products to choose from
delicious not all just nuts that's what
i'm saying because they have delicious
healthy kid-friendly snacks like dried
strawberries and custom trail mix
plus they have all the raw roasted
salted and candied nuts you can imagine
even chocolate dipped which are a
personal favorite
right and those um like white chocolate
truffle nuts
you guys treat yourself it's a
family-run business that takes pride in
getting you the freshest ingredients
nuts.com is your one stop online pantry
delivery is fast most orders will ship
the same day and they have fresher
products in the supermarket
so if you want to be a newnutz.com
customer and get free shipping on your
first order
text toast to 64 000. so text t-o-a-s-t
toast to 64 000 to get free shipping on
your first order from nuts.com
that's toast to four thousand terms
apply available at nuts.com
terms sign on up your snack game it's
time you probably don't even realize
that you need to but once you do you'll
be so glad that you did
yeah it's so nice to walk into your
pantry and have things yeah
and have things that excite you and you
know what excites me
excitement and nuts.com we are so
different
okay our next story i'm so sorry to do
this to you i apologize is this chloe
interesting yes but is it the comments
okay okay and i'm only doing it because
like really everyone's talking about it
and i want to
you know we have to get a conversation
and in case
you were wondering what loser on loser
crime looks like
this is it okay so tristan thompson
seems to threaten lamar odom on khloe
kardashian's instagram
the trouble in paradise started when
odom commented hottie and a string of
emojis under
a snap of chloe being a hottie and then
tristan took issue with that writing
quote
god brought you back the first time play
if you want
different results he followed it up with
a more restrained heart heart
drool drool emoji lol
okay here's the thing neither one as far
as i know neither one of these men
are currently linked to chloe in a
romantic way which makes this
the loseriest thing ever it's like she
doesn't want either of you and you're
still fighting over her like
go to sleep you know like get off your
phone yeah um in terms of the actual
fight i am team lamar
um and here's why because it's always
nice to be called a hottie like there's
doesn't have to be romantic and honestly
for tristan to respond
in such a condescending way about like a
very traumatic time
a traumatizing event in lamar's life and
in chloe's life and in
all of our lives yeah i actually am
personally offended by that
and i think and i know he's made
mistakes but i do think we need to
protect lamar odom at all costs
and tristan thompson is not doing that
and therefore i am team lamar
okay and here's i agree with you and i
also think like when you
really think about his comment like it
it's really upsetting
like it's just so wrong it's so
disrespectful yeah also like what are
you saying like are you gonna kill him
you know it's so true like what is under
the surface here no so like it's just
really a crazy thing to say
but i don't know i'm just i'm with like
think about from chloe's pov like both
of these men she loves so much would
have done anything for
like really put her eggs in their
baskets
both disrespected constantly
disappointed her disrespected her she
gave them chances
nope nope nope and now like you're on
instagram like just being so extra and
thirsty when it's like
you couldn't belly up to the bar [ __ ]
off you know what it's like in a public
sphere you're going to pretend like to
be
supportive and defend me
i'm feeling for her like don't talk the
talk when you couldn't walk the walk
oh my god that is so true for both of
them
both they're both in timeout
and tristan look ever since it was
announced that they did break up has
been like trying to
fight that narrative on instagram and
chloe's like not participating in it so
i'm led to believe that they are not
together i honestly think that chloe
needs to restrict
tristan from commenting on her photos
and lamar true because it constantly
puts her in the news cycle like
attached to him i don't think that's
what she wants you see from the show
that like she just wants people to stop
talking about them
like he should think he's able to write
these comments but then they actually
don't post restrict
restrict it's my favorite she's trying
to block them because he'll know and
then
he'll start you know posting stuff just
like do you know what you're right like
every time like when
when that episode happened where scott
like left uh a weird comment on chloe's
instagram and it made news that like
gave her anxiety because her
relationship becomes a part
of a narrative now in the media and that
really like bothered her and so you're
right like they're actually both doing
her disservice because she doesn't want
to be talked about 100 she doesn't want
to be talked about with them and
at one point in her life she did and
they couldn't hack it no and they
embarrassed her for real
multiple she didn't get her low tattoo
removed on her finger like
multiple do you know how painful that
was she had chloe and lamar the show
like there were so many people who
yeah she didn't do all of that just to
be you know commenting on instagram fake
fighting
yeah loser loser talk the talk
walk the law are you ready for our fifth
and final story a little
space news yes virgin galactica
yeah you guys this was a big weekend for
space travel for billionaires
billionaire richard branson soars to
space aboard the virgin galactic flight
british billionaire richard branson on
sunday soared more than 50 miles above
the new mexico desert
aboard his virgin galactic rocket plane
and safely returned in the vehicle's
first fully crewed test flight
to a space a symbolic milestone for a
venture he started 17 years ago
yeah it was really cool honestly like i
don't really know what the point of the
mission was because they just like
floated right and
it's just like recreational space travel
right is he
back down now he's back down yeah it was
just like a quick flight like you know
an amusement park you know you go up you
come down and i think that's going to
become a trend
yeah me too we just we're talking is
going today
shut up yeah one day later it's today or
tomorrow that is his flight that's crazy
and so like these billionaires are just
like spending money on
chilling in space not even chilling just
like seeing it
feeling the zero gravity and then well i
saw a video
of um when they actually got up there
and all the people in the spaceship like
took off their seat belts because they
were experiencing no gravity it was like
so cool and like richard branson was
making this like
weird speech and didn't get out of his
seat so i wonder if he actually did
eventually unbuckle his seatbelt
because the content that i saw he was
still sitting and like what's the point
of going to space if you're not going to
float
that's so interesting he got up here
next time he has to work his way up
he got up there and he was like to all
the kids watching and it's like
no no he was really trying to make it
neil armstrong like he
paid for this yeah yeah exactly he was
really trying to make it like this
inspirational historic moment for
billionaires
and like i don't know i just i wasn't
feeling the emotion behind it because
it's like
you didn't like you didn't like become
an astronaut you just by the way he's
incredibly
impressive and successful and all the
things that he did but he didn't like
you know
become an astronaut by trade like he
just bought a ticket
sort of like out of straight
you're so right yeah but like addison
ray made a joke about herself like
instead of being like to all the kids
who thought you could never
be a journalist so no it's true i just
and also like oh and you're right now
what he did is not
inspirational it's just really cool that
like it's setting like
and for jeff bezos two and like
eventually like if you have enough money
like you can pay to go to space like
that's cool that's not inspiring and i
also want to say
in this life no matter how much money i
ever have you can count on me to stay
firmly on the ground i have literally
no interest first of all imagine how hot
it is in that little container and
there's fire coming out the back oh my
god i'd be sweating my ass
i'm sure they have like crazy ac i don't
think so at all i think so i don't think
that's a priority
i think it is i think like astronaut
like well they're not astronauts again
travelers like
like space travelers the space
traveler's like physical comfort
is a priority oh you think okay they
have spacesuits like it's i mean
literally they're going to the moon they
can put an ac system no but our studios
i personally
um just like run really warm and so i
just feel like the the standard air
conditioning on whatever aircraft i
might board
would just not be enough for me and so
for that reason i would say no also the
seats look very small
is there a bathroom can i have a drink
or a snack like i just don't think that
space travel is for me but that means
there's more seats open for other
billionaires
yeah that's true i don't think space
travel is for you either you know
richard branson's actually like a cool
guy you know
yeah i feel like he's a lot of people's
like idols and he's also the first shark
to go to space
and i feel like not enough people are
talking about that is well first
guest shark to go to space is he when
you're a guest shark you are one of the
sharks you know when i was in the
british virgin islands which
i've always been confused about virgin
company and then like the british virgin
islands because like richard branson
owns like multiple islands
and british virgin islands like are they
named the british virgin islands because
of
richard virgin branson like i i didn't
understand that
you know that's a really good question
and i think there's literally no
affiliation whatsoever but he just like
he owns multiple islands like i'm just
confused the virgin islands
owned by richard branson but there's
also the u.s virgin islands like maybe
he took
virgin for his brand from the islands
but then he's also okay so i went to
virgin gorda which is one of the british
virgin islands
and i was in a cab and the guy was
telling me about how like
the island was completely ravaged by a
hurricane like years ago
and they got like no aid in like
literally richard branson
paid for all the schools to be rebuilt
like he came he rides his bike around
the island
and like he didn't want any recognition
for it like so he really cares about the
virgin islands don't you think he would
like
care because they're like his like i
don't get it yeah there has to be a
connection
yeah i've always wondered unless he's
just obsessed with virgins
no i know i'm telling you i there's no
there's no correlation but like i've
always thought that
someone out there knows and you're gonna
let us know i just feel like there is a
correlation now
he has three islands he's got his one
that
necker mosquito yes i've actually been
to mosquito um
and what was the third one make peace
okay so he doesn't
but there yep so they're in the british
virgin islands like it's very confusing
that is really confusing
i'm sorry that we don't have answers for
you just yet it's disgusting like
the lack of research at this show
[Laughter]
anyways um would you go to space
you know i'm not into heights yeah why
would you test
god like that so and i like earth i
really do i'm happy here for the most
part
so i don't know i don't know what's out
there for me yeah
i wouldn't say i'm like so happy here on
earth but i don't think i would be
happier
i don't think i'd be happier on mars
it's very hot definitely not
maybe pluto we're both like
misunderstood the moon for sure
do you know what year we went to the
moon in 1969
1968 but the year after
such a good song need a remix
informative too so no i don't think i'll
be going to space anytime soon but i
guess that's like what happens when
you've conquered the world you literally
need to go find a new one
i just feel like we still have like like
tons of problems here on earth that i
think we should focus our energy and
finances on
for me personally like i'm just not done
like i haven't i feel like i've barely
scratched the surface of earth yeah and
don't get me wrong like i think space
research and exploration is such an
important part of our existence like
nasa
i just don't think it's on like the
private citizen billionaires like it's
our job
like to figure that out like leave it up
but then but then like what about elon
musk
he works with nasa correct spacex does
work with nasa but like that is a
private citizen billionaire like really
making waves in space travel
yeah i guess what i'm trying to say here
is my opinion on certain things just
depends on who's involved just depends
on who you're talking about and as long
as i'm open about that
i feel like i can't be really blamed i
would say elon musk is everything's
positive
jeff bezos everything's negative richard
branson neutral no i agree and richard
branson's also british
and i think that's important because
like we have like our own weird things
in america like everyone like
like different social issues and i don't
really feel like that applies in britain
maybe i'm wrong no
i mean people were upset that that's
what he used his like billions
oh really yeah but i feel like he's also
very philanthropic but also like
whenever anything happens anything just
could be theo chewing on this bone like
people will be upset about it so i don't
know
how what percentage of people are upset
yeah i guess like when anything happens
you can expect a 15 backlash and if it's
anything more than that then it's
something to respond to
i mean no i feel like when anything
happens you can expect like even like
zero zero one percent backlash but if
you want to focus on that
sure yeah but it also could be 99 so i
don't know
what percent of his space travel was
backlash i hadn't seen the backlash but
um
i i think space exploration is fabulous
i don't know if i would say they didn't
expect that's what i was gonna say i
don't know if i would
categorize this particular adventure as
space
exploration but again it's like if i had
a billion dollars and i wanted to
explore the inside of your butthole like
let me do that you know you don't need a
billion to do that yes i do because i
would have to shrink us all down that's
how much you would have to pay me to get
in there
okay fine but i would also need the
technology to shrink my spaceship
and myself down to like little the size
of a
they already have that technology for
colonoscopies
so you could actually see inside of my
[ __ ] probably like for free with
insurance
no but i would want to go in myself as
an explorer like richard branson did
so i think instead of making you smaller
we need to make me
bigger oh yeah we'll give you the
biggest [ __ ] this world has ever
seen how does that sound i'm good okay
i'm really good so all in all those were
the fast five stories
lots of things going on in the world and
the earth no the solar system yes and
the orbits
the planetarium yeah um all right let's
dive into the tv recap because i have so
much to say
about real housewives of potomac
probably as much as you have to say
about gossip girl no i have so much to
say about potomac too i didn't need to
just get it out before like i forget
and today's tv recap segment is brought
to you by betterhelp is there something
interfering with your happiness or is
preventing you from you
from achieving your goals i know for me
i have you know crippling self-doubt
lots of anxiety
uh getting older seasonal depression is
so true um
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapists where you can
start communicating in under 48 hours
better help is not a crisis line it is
professional counseling done securely
online
the service is available for clients
worldwide where you can log into your
account anytime
and send a message to your counselor
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions so you won't
ever have to sit in an uncomfortable
waiting room as you do with traditional
therapy
betterhelp is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid
is available betterhelp wants you to
start living a happier life today
visit betterhelp.com toast that's
betterhelp.com
toast join the over a million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional
the podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and if you want that 10 off your first
month
go to betterhelp.com toast thank you for
that
all right let's start with the real
houses of potomac because it's just like
bursting out of me
the ladies are back monique is gone
unfortunately candace is not
and we have mia and i just have to say
ev i think first episodes are usually
kind of boring because everyone's just
kind of like getting their bearings
there's very rarely a fight there was a
fight
and it was so layered i was shocked
here's why
and you know i don't like wendy yeah
that's just the fact i just wanted to
put that in there um
please do the fight like that what was
outbreaking between gisele and karen
and the most shocking thing wendy
inviting everyone over to her house to
basically show off her breasts
talk about her plastic surgery nude
interlude and then had a cake with boobs
cupcakes literally wore a sexy dress
told made an announcement that was three
hours long about my boobs boobs
boobs plastic surgery i was living for
my kids i was
breastfeeding all day pumping all day
three hours what else did you get done
what else have you had done no like
literally i am
all about like whatever you want to get
done you don't have to tell anyone same
but
if you're going to make me drive two
hours to celebrate your new plastic
surgery i want to hear
everything you got and by the way no i
don't want i need to either what are we
doing there she would
interlude she looks amazing unbelievable
she definitely got some sort of like
tummy tuck because
they showed the they showed them playing
with her stomach yeah i think she got
some she definitely got like fillers and
stuff i think she also might have done a
nose job
whatever it is she's never looked better
i was literally like going to write down
that doctor's name and drive to between
literally
she looks unbelievable and so like
wouldn't you want to share that and it's
like
all right i guess you want to maybe say
like all right i naturally look this way
but then you wouldn't have a whole party
about your boobs so she was just being
really weird and like
hypocritical in inviting the women in to
talk about plastic surgery and then like
not sharing the full story and getting
offended when mia was like what else
have you had done and then she's like
well what else have you had done
and mia's response and not even she said
what else have you have done because you
look like you've had one so rude to a
new person who's in your home who's
literally just asking a very fair
question when you're having a plastic
surgery party right
such a rude response mia has the best
answer she just started listening off
everything she's ever had done which is
a lot she had her [ __ ] done like
i just loved her honesty because if
you're gonna ask a question like that
you have to be prepared
to answer it yourself agreed i just have
to say so far i know it's only episode
one i really like mia i'm sorry i
laughed at her tag line i take it back
i'm so glad she's there a friend for
karen like someone
an ally and also like she seems like a
great woman she has her stuff together
sure of herself confident like we'd love
to see it
and also like we just need more people
on team karen ashley
100 and also with interesting
backgrounds like her husband's 30 years
older than her
she has grandkids but she's 32. it's
just it's so
interesting 36. whatever and like
people's live life choices
even though they're not my life choices
i find them fascinating like yeah and i
thought a lot of the women were being
like a little judgmental but maybe that
was just like the editing they didn't
say anything they were just like making
faces
um but giselle's just gonna hate anyone
who comes in with karen
and honestly and giselle like really is
rude to everyone who comes in period
period literally the hypocrisy that is
gisele is so frustrating she refuses to
acknowledge karen because karen
was talking about jamal's infidelity at
the reunion basically giselle
feels like that is an affront to her
family to her kids disrespect
and while that that could potentially be
true has gisele been
blind to what she's been doing to every
single housewife since
giselle is the bone collector she
exposes things going on in people's
family
she was the one who brought up the
rumors last season that monique's kid
wasn't
chris's right dad like she has literally
exposed things going on in people's
personal lives their families their
husbands their kids
and now she's the story of the century
and you're mad at someone from bringing
it up
also she brings up like unverified
rumors like
conspiracy theories about her cast mates
because she thinks that that
the jamal story was everywhere like it
wasn't just like oh i told this it's
fact yeah so her to for her to be so
upset at karen like she really can't
even see
her own self and it looks like later in
the season she brings up some unverified
rumors about eddie
and it's just like th you that is you
wha
what would you i would want to see the
energy giselle brings to what giselle
and jamal have going on if it were
someone else
exactly and honestly i believe it's
wendy who says to giselle i'm not sure
if it's pointed to giselle
you had turned out to be everything and
everyone said you were and it has to be
the gisele 100
and i just want to let you know like
that will be the redeeming moment for me
i felt the same way like i actually you
have to learn
even in just watching that preview like
it made me like
wendy moore in this episode because it's
the perfect thing to say and you know of
course when he's new to the group she's
not going to come in and just like
hate giselle because of what people said
about her a nice person would give
gisele the benefit of the doubt until
they've wronged her and it appears
that giselle does i hope that's it has
to be pointed towards gizelle i agree
i'm so excited for that
um gisele and candice like having fruit
and mimosas like i've never seen
anything more fake in my life like
even when gizelle was just like touring
her house just like everything was just
like there's no genuine friendship
they're like united in hatred against
monique and karen and then they were
juxtaposing like the scene of
giselle and candace like talking [ __ ]
about karen and and
ray with karen and ryan their home and
they've literally never looked happier
like
laughing so much just like having such a
good time and it's like
giselle is so bitter so bitter and also
like she just you know what i really
don't like one of my least favorite
things when people do like in
in friendships is i open up to you about
something that's going on in my life
whether it's something i'm vulnerable
about in my
marriage and when we're in a bad place
you throw that back at me so last season
karen was very open about like her and
rey
sexually like just we're not connecting
and twice this episode she's like your
husband dick is broke like
it's so disrespectful to throw the thing
that karen was like open and vulnerable
about and giselle's new thing this
season which is just like
so corny she's like i'm gonna bring out
all the truths like she said to candace
and then like she literally repeated at
the table and it's like that's not that
strong of a line that like
it's worth repeating whatever um and
everything that she's saying are all
things that like
karen has been pretty open about so it's
like what truth did you uncover
yeah nothing we knew that she was broke
all right i i don't know if i knew that
she struggled with alcohol but like
again
that doesn't make you a bad person when
she got drunk last season and told them
all these things that she wouldn't have
and then she
really stopped drinking and then they
were like mad at her for not drinking at
every occasion like
there's like no no there's nothing there
being
struggling with alcohol doesn't make you
a bad person it makes you just human
right right like something about
cheating they already said that about
cameras nothing that she was like i know
i'm like oh okay what are you finally
gonna say apparently you've been holding
which by the way gisele and karen have
been
hating each other for so long there's no
way that this is her breaking point like
she's had all these things she's been
sitting on and
protecting karen from because she's
hated karen for so long she would have
thrown if there was an actual
big ass secret she would have thrown it
out there years ago she has no
self-control when it comes to gossip
karen is just everything she was looking
amazing i just like i need this season
to provide justice and i guess at the
end of the day it is justice for monique
and everything that happened last season
but it's justice team
karen and ashley and ashley is just so
cute and so pregnant
i'm like she's obviously not going to
get involved in a lot but i look forward
to when she comes back
yeah with ashley especially like with
some of the home stuff it's just like
i don't like michael and i find their
scenes to be like annoying because
there's just like always so much drama
so it's like he's such a great dad but
it's like
he was also like running around with
strippers when you were pregnant like
yeah it's frustrating
but there is and i was watching the
reunion from last season it aired right
before
there is something admirable about the
way literally ashley will defend her
husband
even when he's so guilty you know what i
mean like yeah that's a true marriage
like
like literally so fiercely believes in
him
and believes him to be a good person and
will literally go down
for him it's shocking yeah i think
a lot of things first of all it's crazy
how every season like michael darby does
something so [ __ ] crazy it's like how
is he going to come back from this and
then the next season is nothing
like forget what happened with him he
needs to just seriously stay off the
show
no i know he can't but i think for
ashley like
and i feel like she kind of says this at
some point like she knows what
her marriage is like she is in it like
for the things that make her happy like
she has her kids like
i think that they just have a different
sort of relationship and she's not
trying to make it something that it
isn't
right and she's happy with that it's
like a different approach to marriage
100 yeah i agree um i do like i do
wish justice for her as well like i'm
hoping and i don't know where the
where do are we unique in taking the
sides of the minority or does everyone
feel like monique was kind of wronged
and
bravo choosing like candace and giselle
as like the
like does it do people agree with us i
don't know i used to
sometimes like look at twitter um after
each episode i didn't do that last night
so i don't know where people stand
that were unique or no people agree with
us justice for monique
okay yeah because like i don't know how
you could side like robin dixon even
though
i have to say i've actually never
related more to robin dixon when she was
talking about how like she just shut the
[ __ ] down and covered like she doesn't
get out of bed like
i don't even have kids and i did that
and like i can imagine how overwhelming
it must have been so i actually found
her
oddly uh i found myself having empathy
for her because that is actually a very
real thing
i felt the exact same thing um it's a
very real thing i think later in the
season it becomes more
of a problem concerning and i think that
sometimes that can be a red flag when
like someone
can't get out of bed doesn't want to get
out of bed it's the first sign of
depression
yes and so although
we have our hearts on her our issues
with robin
um i found that to be very relatable as
well and
in the preview now i don't know if this
actually happens they do make it seem
like there be
is a break between gisele and robin
which would really throw this entire
season
flew a loop i don't know the phrase
through a loop
doula peep like it's a tick-tock joke
um that would be like
a a groundbreaking shift that would give
i think like the next couple seasons of
potomac some of their best
yet i agree and also it looks like in
the previews that
mia has issues with candace yes which
everyone has issues with
that was not shocking i'm just looking
forward to that um
i was really not looking forward to
watching last night because i was i'm
just
i'm still upset i'm still upset even
when they were flashing back to previews
and i remember like i think it was
around um
christmas time that those episodes aired
and like we watch the reviews
just so upsetting and like i really
didn't want to watch a show because like
the outcome was not one in
that i thought was fair yeah but now i
feel
excited once more because i do feel like
there is a path to justice
no i know and like we're actually living
it's a great time of year like
beverly hills and i i was actually
thinking about this last night so much
has changed in the bravo universe in
these last couple years
i would say that the best two real
housewives franchises are beverly hills
and potomac
and they're both on right now yeah so
it's a good time it is a good time to be
a bravo fan we went through some dark
times like we were watching osea new
york at the same time like we deserve
justice you know
justice for us and dallas no offense
like
it's a good time yeah and i just um i
can't tell you how excited i am
for like the next seasons of real
housewives and i actually feel like
the these have been some of the worst
seasons because of like all the cool
stuff and like just to like watch these
dinner parties with the mask and like i
just
i'm so past it but also some franchises
have deep-rooted casting problems that
are not gonna be solved
because of covid oh yes yes but even the
best of shows like it's just like it's
every obviously everything wasn't great
this is everything's being held back
because of co-video and now like we're
living in a post-pandemic world and
we're watching pandemic [ __ ] and yes
that i really it's bothersome yes but
we're going to push forward yes but i
just want to say like it's really
annoying
a hundred percent especially because
like tonight or tomorrow night on real
housewives beverly hills like i'm pretty
sure they get kobe yes
when we were having so much momentum
like with eric so much no it's so true
um but potomac i i agree like i have a
lot of
high hopes for yes all right let's talk
about gossip girl
first season of the first episode of the
reboot dropped on hbo max i do want to
preface by saying
i don't really think i've ever watched a
reboot no i feel like we talk about them
all the time but i've never
like actually done it i had seen like a
little bit of fuller house because i was
like curious but that doesn't really
count like
so i don't think i generally even like
reboots i just want to say that because
i did not like this
obviously i did not like this but i
didn't
i thought i wasn't going to like it
based on just like the previews but i
wound up not liking it just for
other reasons not why i thought i wasn't
gonna let's start with the positives
okay i do think that some the the
group of cool kids is cast very well i
think that that girl zoya
the younger sister is like the prettiest
girl i've ever seen in my life the boys
are handsome
i love that it's a diverse cast i
actually think
they did great on the casting and the
the social
scene of new york like dumbo house is
obviously dumbo
they why are hall upper east side kids
going dumbo because jumbo like the cool
kids are like brooklyn like that that
actually
is i guess it also might be accurate
with it is like i don't know
what the upper east side high school or
16 year olds are doing today i really
don't so i don't know
like if i think they could be going to
dumbo house for sure okay like
don't you have to be 21 to be a member
like oh true but like i guess
the the vibe is like they're too rich
and powerful they don't need ids like i
guess
okay cool i agree the casting is on
point there are some people who are
early favorites i don't know if i'm
gonna keep watching so i don't know if
they're like gonna be also my
last favorites as well um but the
casting
was good what made the original show so
many thoughts okay what made the
original show so good were i think a
number of things like obviously
the story and whatnot but the fashion
the music and the new york elements and
i feel like
this reboot did not have those things i
feel like the fashion was fine but
they're not setting any new trends some
of what they were wearing it's like no
one would [ __ ] wear that yeah like
when gossip girl first came out like
everybody started to dress like that yes
and i feel like i don't like i said i
don't know what 16 year olds on the
upper east side are wearing these days
but i do feel like it's more akin to
like what we see on tick tock
yes than what we saw on gossip girl like
those big jeans
yeah and then yeah the dino stompers and
like i just
i don't feel like they nailed it on the
fashion like there are some cute fashion
moments but overall like they don't
stress they don't have like a vibe the
orange dress was cute but like
even that blonde girl what she wore to
dumbo house is literally like what a 40
year old woman would wear to a
conference
yeah no you're right and it's just like
no she's probably 15 in the show like
she's not wearing a dress below her
knees and pumped yeah no and
i guess this is a problem with the
original gossip girl too they're juniors
in high school and don't get me wrong
kids who grew up in the city
go to private school have enormous
wealth they grow up fast not
that fast like it's not that crazy no
but it's
it's just actually it is like they go to
clubs and they really act like they
are 21 year old adults they don't dress
like that no so i felt like
the fashion which was like literally
probably one of the most important
tenets of the original show
was not there not yet two the music
i did not think was good either there
was nothing from the show i wanted to
shazam like all the songs were just like
so elevated music exactly elevator music
and three new york we literally got like
nothing we got the mets
and i know they filmed during kobe but
like i'm sorry that's not an excuse if
you want to bring back
an amazing show 10 years later then then
maybe you should wait until you can film
the city i agree there was no new york
there was no fabulousness
none also okay okay and then oh wait
let's talk about the plot can i just say
one more thing because snitch said this
and i actually
totally agreed with her if this was a
show and i think she probably
saw this like take on tick tock if this
was a show that was not a reboot it was
just like
this show period called new york city
prep whatever it would be
better than the fact that there's a
legacy that it would be better
than it being a gossip girl reboot
because you're always going to compare
it to the original and it's just not as
good and it's not fair and it should
it should just be called something else
yes because i do have to say
i one pro is i actually do like how they
regard the original gossip girl then
again nate archibald one here it's like
a funny unique way but most
kids actually today like don't haven't
even seen gossip girl so like
i do think it was a nice homage and a
good way of like addressing the elephant
in the room
but the show completely lost me
like when when they made the horrendous
choice
to make those four losery ass teachers
gossip girl
you're telling me you are going to sit
here and tell me in my face
that these four grown ass adults went to
college
grad school probably got their masters
in education
worked their way up to one of the best
private schools in manhattan
just to start a blog is that what you're
telling instagram account that's what
they're telling you
there's no [ __ ] way first of all so
inappropriate teacher-like conduct
standing outside the window while the
girl is changing taking a picture of her
like are you [ __ ] serious it wasn't
until i could get behind the teacher
element like the kids make their lives
miserable and like these are just like
some
pressed teachers and they want to get
back at them but what would that that
wasn't even
the one that they wanted to get why back
they wanted to steer them in the
righteous direction that's not gonna do
that
but once the grown man took
the peeping tom photo of thomasina
freshman i'm gonna say 14 year old
in her bra and underwear that was where
you lost me
yeah and so i didn't like honestly i
think the premise of knowing who gossip
girl was like does add another element
but like the fact that it was the
teachers like i was like this show is is
a joke they're not taking the legacy of
gossip girl seriously like this is
disgusting
also i agree completely
agree nothing more to say about the
teachers because i'm just shocked it's
so upsetting
what also was oh sorry can i say one
more thing about the teachers yeah
okay so at the end of the episode
they're like
they hark back to the first minute when
you know um
julian i think her name is knocks the
coffee out of the tea the blonde
teachers
um tabby gevinson i sent you that who's
a
she was like a blogger a kid blogger
back in the day and i thought she looked
familiar but also she like also looks
like scarlett johansson she talks like
her
i never heard of her okay i sent yeah i
know i remember
she's just like a fashion kid okay
whatever
so she spills coffee on the teacher in
the first episode and is so mean to her
julian wasn't so mean to her was the
other girls oh was she right because
julian
really wasn't mean to anybody so then i
was like is julian supposed to be mean
because
when that scene when she embraced her
sister in the bathroom i was like
so cute i couldn't get a read on
anything the show was very
what the [ __ ] did she airdrop to
everyone at the fashion show
they never showed us literally the show
had so many continuity issues i was like
what it was so it was her plan and then
it was her plan and then she co-op
or what the [ __ ] happened this was my
next comment which was like the original
gossip girl the scheming was so
on point and in the first major scheme
of the episode i couldn't even
tell you what happened what did she
airdrop i think a picture of thomas
jordy's penis
who max i think his name is but i know
him because he's from descendants
who's penis is that her boyfriend no the
the guy who's doing drugs
the whole time that's like the chuck
bass yeah yeah what would that have to
do
with who used to date dove cameron he's
from descendants oh cute
what would that have to do with the
sisters okay so i guess
like this is me really trying to like
play devil's advocate and trying to
understand what happened
and how do you know it was a penis shot
because she was like unbuttoning his
pants styling him
for the shot oh
she took a picture of his penis i think
she air dropped it to everyone in the
room from zoya's phone from zoya's phone
i guess she
dropped it to the security guards too
because they kicked her out for air
dropping a picture of a penis they never
said that you couldn't do that
so and then yes and then julian was
supposed to from her perch on the runway
say leave her and the security guards
would listen to the model
right even though they were escorting
her because she broke this penis rule
so i guess like the the scheme was
supposed to be like zoya
tried to ruin her sister's moment at the
fashion show but instead got kicked out
embarrassingly
yeah so that's the worst scheme my
biggest issue like it's the first
episode like there are schemes of plenty
yeah and that's what you came up with
like blair waldorf is rolling over in
her grave
also the script trash one-liners
the insults in the original gossip girl
like the blair-isms like
iconic nothing no i needed to see more
wealth as well like we saw the entryway
to all of their homes like show me the
house
yeah come in the house where do they
live uptown downtown townhouse
penthouse like there was nothing there
was no new york there was no real estate
yeah there was nothing also one final
thought that i had which i'm just
forgetting give me one second take your
time
oh [ __ ] i can't remember no you'll
remember it was um
the teachers again it was always the
teachers i can't remember
it was just like i really did want to
like it but
maybe it's because kovid but it just
should have been way better
it was just really not good for how much
time energy resources et cetera like
marketing
every time i watch an instagram story
the next one is for gossip girl yeah
it's everywhere
and it's just like not that strong and i
feel like if you want to bring back an
iconic show
it has to be all of those things and it
really missed the mark on so many but i
really thought it was going to be like
that show because there's been so much
marketing for it like such a big push
i'm like oh this is gonna be like the
hbo max like thing it's gonna be huge
yeah and just like wasn't it's already
been renewed for season two
i'm probably not gonna make it there but
that but again maybe i just don't like
reboots
i don't like reboots i also don't like
you know 15 year old drama so
maybe we're just too old for it but like
i don't i don't think it was
beloved by by most i was looking on
twitter i was sending you like some of
the fun it was
so funny because it was just like so
outlandish yeah and the teacher was like
it's just unacceptable
there there could have been a way to get
a photo where you weren't taking a
picture of an underage girl in her life
like somebody like
sent it as a tip somebody sent it as a
tip or like they were just in the window
like talking closely to each other not
taking their clothes off
right and so they were leaving dumbo
house and he lived right around the
corner but they all apparently live on
the upper east side
but not him okay yeah because the
brooklyn bridge was in the background
and asked me if i followed
anything that was going on with the rest
of the group like the blonde girl and
her boyfriend like
thinking about the other guy they're
both in love with chuck bass like
i couldn't remember anyone's name i'm
sorry is that
am i following that correctly like
they're like in a loveless relationship
because they're both in love with that
other guy and they're obviously gonna
end up having a threesome i think that
they should be a throuple
yeah i don't know and something's
different like everything was just like
so implied and we're like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about
and also they didn't introduce us to
anyone like we were just supposed to
follow along who everyone is where
they're from
what their name is like i got no
introduction to anyone like we showed
the blonde girl [ __ ] her boyfriend
i'm like well are they in a relationship
are they having like a secret affair
they gave us nothing there was no
narrator yeah well there
was eventually but it was just not good
it was not good i'm really sorry it's a
mess
yeah but there might be potential it
needs to work though
yeah i yeah they need like new writers
and
things but also the original was so good
was based on the books which were
bestsellers for a reason
yeah like there's just no plot there's
no more story because the books are over
yeah it was an easy show to make because
it was already written yeah
and like so but cecily vaughn ziggsler
is just rolling in it
it didn't make me re want to re-watch
the original gossip girl
i have not done that i did it like i
think in college
yeah i don't even know if it was over
yet definitely not but
it was just so good so maybe i'll do
that but like i can't
this is my thing with like watching tv
like i get so sucked in like last night
i was up like way later than i should
have been because i needed to finish
medici and like i need to go to the next
episode it's like addicting
of course and you have to break the
cycle you do so i don't know that i want
to get engrossed in another television
so i won't leave my room for like four
days that sounds amazing
no it's not amazing it does not feel
good it does i know because this weekend
i was so excited because i was like i'm
gonna sleep in i'm just gonna
i haven't had like a weekend like that
we're supposed to get our patreon vlog
up right
but then we like didn't have the we
never air dropped it to each other that
is coming soon it's coming today really
sorry we felt really bad about it yeah
it was 100 like our fault
we were like facetiming both having kids
like yeah because i have some of the
videos on my phone jackie some of them
on her phone like we can't
send them because they're too big so we
have to be together and air drop them
and we weren't together all weekend like
right
we're really sorry attacked in my
television right it's basically the
television's all no it's just it's
really
toxic like sure there's a lot of
entertaining content but it's really
hard to wean yourself off yeah
and i spent most of the weekend just
like watching tv and like i did not feel
good
i actually felt quite bad i i hear you i
can't really relate to that particular
sentiment but i
i have a lot of empathy for what you're
going through no now i've broken the
cycle because i got
here too okay that's so good um but i do
need to watch the third season of medici
so who knows girl's got to do what she's
got to do
and now that just means we're gonna have
a really robust tv recap segment also
i don't want to do like a whole love
island recap because i want you to catch
up
but um it was getting a little slow i'm
not gonna lie but last night's episode
was
two hours it was actually pretty good
like cause there was a recoupling
ceremony did things like pop
off yes so they had a challenge could i
tell you what happened i don't know
i'll just i'll skip the episode so the
new girl came i've watched everything
except last night new girl came
and she took out josh she took out yeah
and it looked like they were hitting it
off yeah but then she got
two more dates and she asked jeremy out
and jeremy was also like having a lot of
cold feet expressing to the women
to the men he was saying one thing to
the man and trina was saying something
yeah so like
they it made trina look so sad and
desperate but he really did not
communicate they went on a date and he
was like i'm happy with where we are
and then he goes home and says like i
told her and she had a completely
different experience
he was gaslighting her for sure and she
was heartbroken when he ended
it with her and he ended it with her at
the same time he was like starting to
buy with amy and she got a date and she
took him
and trina trina was just like left in
the dust so in the recoupling ceremony
like she just chose corey who like no
one has spoken to because
she had no one else to talk to and she
thinks like maybe there could be
something there she's also
like having regrets about cinco as she
should because
cinco is the best guy on the show i love
him he's honestly i was thinking like if
i was on the show i would go for cinco
he's so sweet he's not a player
he chose cachet and he was like we
really built a friendship and like every
night now they're making out and they're
actually really cute
and like they had to do this challenge
where like they would like do a sexy
walk on the beach and then like pick a
girl to kiss
and they had like the cute he was walk
was so cute they had the cutest kiss
like
trina is living a life of regret because
cashew is living the life that she
thinks she should have
and it's really hard for her so she just
chose corey like in a moment of
desperation
amy went on the date with jeremy really
vibes and then amy got another date and
chose
will okay the new um colombian guy
and so he was told kira kira is like
so fragile she's so fragile he told kira
he was like i'm gonna go like i want to
like you know be open and she was
devastated he went on the date
they like vibed really well he came back
and he told her like you know i'm gonna
explore it with her and with you you
know and she was
unwell like so frazzled then like
later that night he just went back and
was like i'm sorry actually i changed my
mind like i want to stick with you and
she was like happy about it but like
now like a little you know on edge so
basically that really left amy with
jeremy i don't know if she would have
chosen will but amy and jeremy were cute
but like it leaves
and i was like i don't know how to feel
because i love trina i love jeremy and i
loved them as a couple
and i don't know if i love jeremy with
this girl like it's i don't know if
she's the one for him like i had a lot
of like love for him and trina
so in the recoupling ceremony trina
chose
corey uh that girl olivia who's like
stuck in a love triangle
with two nobodies chose the one that she
was already with giovanni
okay um in the challenge
okay wait sorry so when they got back
from the hot tub date amy and josh
shannon i mean she might have been drunk
but she was just like pissed and so she
was thinking i don't think they can get
that drunk i don't think they get that
much
i would think of the same thing because
with cbs they they give you a limited
amount so she was just being irrational
she was like obviously jealous and i
thought that actually would have made
josh
like happy because he likes her so much
more than she likes him yeah she's
finally showing like she cares and he's
like this is a red flag like you're
acting crazy
so the next morning she was like i'm
sorry i was just like jealous i'm really
happy with where we are and he was like
it's fine it was just like a red flag
like a little bit of a turn off
but they made up honestly shannon
deserves that like she was so rude to
him and about him the first night i
don't know what changed for her
but she did not appreciate him and i
actually like don't
like her oh i like her but wait listen
then in the challenge
they all do their sexy walks he josh
does a sexy walk and pulls amy to kiss
but he like threw his hat to jaw to
shannon when he was like taking off his
sexy outfit like
and so everyone obviously like she like
stepped forward for the kiss
and he went in for amy and it was
honestly so awkward and
she was furious and then it was like
girls you're in charge of the recoupling
session
so he was like alpha clamped he made the
worst mistake ever it was like the
morning of the recoupling matching
ceremony
and he's dissing the only girl he has a
chance with right and she was basically
like if you wanted to explore other
people like that's fine but you
embarrass me like so hard like everyone
was like
like feeling bad for me i i hate that
you disrespect me in front in front of
everyone you obviously just don't have
respect for me
and you embarrass me like it's not about
you kissing amy that's fine like it
really is
it's the way you did it like that really
really hurt my feelings so she was
basically saying
she was gonna choose christian or
giovanni who have like nothing going on
right now
yeah to save because they deserve to be
there more than josh and then in the
recoupling ceremony she chose josh like
it was just so stupid and then i'm like
okay girl i have no respect for you
because he was being a fuckboy he did
disrespect her
and if you want to have some respect
from yourself send him home and then
that guy christian went home who
honestly should have went home because
he doesn't have a connection with the
plants
let alone another person in the house
but right i i mean i don't think would
make sense for joshua whom he seems to
be like to the job yeah and maybe
shannon and josh can get on good footing
from here i just like really didn't like
how she treated him in the first episode
not to like judge her so prematurely and
maybe i'll feel differently after i
watch
last night they're on even they're even
now honestly josh is indebted to her but
now it's like
she when it's the guy's coupling
ceremony she has a lot to worry about
because he's a fuckboy and he's
obviously not like ride or die for her
it's that's so weird because everything
that i've seen he's been he was so right
it was a total shift last night's
episode
of who he is cinco and cachet chose each
other and like when they were like
choosing each other in the ceremony
trina looked like she literally wanted
to jump off the cliff like i actually
felt so bad for her
because she has exactly what what they
want she's made it very clear now like
she's
here for a relationship she's talking to
jeremy about doing long distance when
they get home on their date
and he's just like not into it at all i
know i saw that
so it's like i feel bad for trina but
she did put all of her eggs in one
basket
jeremy did mislead her a hundred percent
but now she's kind of left with nothing
damn okay so maybe i should watch last
night's episode it was good it was so
long
it was like it was honestly the first
thing like really not a lot
happened nothing and it really didn't
feel like there were strong connections
you know they were just sort of like
trying to make stuff happen i felt like
actually karen will
were becoming the strongest but there
were the waters were tested this week
between here as well the waters are
always going to be tested and next week
like
we're sorry tonight new guys are going
to come in no so then in the preview
tonight's episode is street girl sorry
tonight's episode is streaming on
paramount plus it's like a bonus episode
i don't think we need to watch it no you
don't
then the new people come on tuesday back
on cbs okay and there's gonna be new
girls
yes there's three new girls and one new
guy and a lot of the new girls
they said they want to go on a date with
cinco so that's going to be interesting
because
i really like cachet and him i think
like i they've really i didn't think
they were a match at first but they've
really just like
started out as friends and now every
night they're just like grabbing each
other's asses like it's actually really
cute
that is really cute but now a lot of the
new girls are gonna come for it
i'm glad things are picking up just wait
i heard that this season they're
bringing back um
casa moore what's up oh my god it was
this thing that happened last season
where basically
the guys leave the house all the guys
and they go to another house called
casamore
where there's five new girls there and
the girls
stay at the house and five new guys come
in oh and so they see if they want to
stay in the relationship or pursue
anything new with new people that's
crazy
and at last season the strongest couple
johnny and sally
johnny went into casa morgan like i
remember you telling me this and he
ditched his day one girl for some random
new girl and just like
lost his mind and casa more and then
came back and like thought
he could like not tell anyone but all
the people by the way when new people
come onto the show
they've been watching everything so all
the new people would come on and be like
sally you need to have shawnee about
custom right and it was just like the
craziest thing cost them more
anyways they're doing it again that's
good yeah no it was like really funny
it's definitely starting slow and i
think that like
it being on for six weeks like it could
be on for three and they could just like
do more each episode but whatever i'm
having fun yeah no and it's nice they
really switch up the cast a lot so it's
like it's good
yes it was really sad can i tell you
when i went home yes please
christian oh you already said that the
guy with the blob you already said that
because he couldn't connect with the
plan he couldn't connect with anyone but
like he was
so sad to be leaving he's like when you
guys leave here i want to be the first
person you see like
it's like he's gonna have so much for
like not even from being famous around
the show because i didn't get that vibe
from him just because he's having a good
time he's friends with everyone and
he was actually an integral part of this
episode he's he's the biggest [ __ ]
talker
because the guys talk and the girls talk
and the only way to know about what the
guys are talking about is because
christian runs and tells everyone like
he's a snitch and you actually need a
person like that
or else there's because he was the one
who gave a heads up to cache and was
like jeremy is not into trina like
you've got to tell your girl
and cachet was like giving her a pep
talk like maybe you shouldn't put all
your eggs in his basket
like i don't know yeah and that wouldn't
have happened without
the snitch christian interesting yeah so
you're going to need a new person like
that
okay well i'm sure they'll they'll make
a new person like that like that's what
producers are for yeah
um so that was the longest tv recap
segment we've ever had on our show
[Music]
and that's it yeah anything else you
want to say
no i think that's it we'll be back
tomorrow for another wonderful show so
we'll see you then and until then hope
you all stay well have an amazing day
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast of the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
heard video cast box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcast
find us morning chelsea five star review
about how beautiful stunning it's more
we are hope you guys have an amazing day
we'll see you tomorrow for tuesday's
show have a great day goodbye
you